It is giving her everything she wanted, and it wasn't enough.
None of it was enough for her. Where do these people get off?
You're a Destiny orbiter, bro. None of it was enough for Wick.
None of it is enough for any of these people. They're like building
their houses out of straw. The big bad wolf barely even got a
puff. Ain't even huffing and puffing, and the house collapses.
They're a bunch of straw house piggies, okay? They got nothing.
>> So, how did this all start out? How did this whole thing
start out? This Stardust thing, this Wick thing. There's like
two different things happening. One of the things is
all right? Basically trying to be super apologetic
Destiny. So, he'd be feeling super bad for Destiny.
He was He was feeling bad for Destiny. So, we watched the clip
yesterday that Wick is talking about, right? This is the clip
of Destiny complaining about how he >> money for each regular
stream, if it's worth skipping events for grinding streams, it's
not worth it to skip.
Wait, no. Yes, I The only money that I make right now is from
streaming on Kick. So, when I do events, it costs me a considerable
amount of money. Yes. And then I'm getting squeezed from way
too many places right now with zero
Wait, where is he getting squeezed from? I didn't I didn't think
to ask this last
But where is he getting squeezed from? I know about the
I know about the Pixie lawsuit. Is he getting squeezed from another
place? I Like at what point do you just go, "Oh, maybe like downgrade
your lifestyle."
Why do you have these these apartments in this place? Like Like
surely you're not going to re-up your lease in the same apartment,
right?
What is that? Like five, seven grand a month or something like
that?
There's no way
that you would keep you would maintain the same lifestyle, right?
So, one like where's the, you know, you got to got to move that
lifestyle back to where your income is, probably.
But also, where else would you be getting squeezed from?
Right? Maybe take your own advice and just move. Just move, man.
Yeah, exactly. I I just don't know where else the squeeze is
from. I'm getting squeezed from multiple places, and I have no
external support.
Where would you be getting external support from with regards
to like your lawsuits and And then
What? Where are you
Are you getting squeezed? >> zero external support, so
cuz I don't have YouTube money. Um the Kick Once again,
it would be better if he didn't have like a a smug attitude about
this. He should be crying, right? Like let's see the tears. You
want to play the victim, put the tears on. You want to go on
your stream, like Tectone, talk about what a massive victim you
are, and cry, then cry.
Don't go live and sort of hint that you're not that you're like
suffering, but you're just too stoic to talk about it. You You're
not. You are You are just lying. You're just putting a mask on.
Put the tears Get the tears out, okay? Show me some emotion.
Show me some feeling.
Kick sub doesn't count as well as it used to. And then between
core costs
and then taking time off to travel and do events or whatever,
it's a lot. It's a big People talk about the Kick payments going
down. The Kick payment for me has not gone down. My Kick payments
are basically locked in to exactly what they were before.
I've not seen the Kick money go down at all. I'm very shocked
that so many people talk about how the Kick money's gone down.
I don't see it. Where is that happening that the Kick money has
gone down?
I actually have no idea. A big old
Cuz they bought? Well, I don't know. I don't know what's going
on there. But my My money's never gone down. Wick decided to
come in and say, "Important lesson here. Never ever hint that
you are suffering online." The most vile people imaginable will
gloat and celebrate. Terrible to see.
Uh I don't I don't know how Wick is talking about this. Destiny
himself
uh Destiny believes he's doxxed me, and apparently some person
died in the place where he thinks I live. And he said that was
my dad, and he thought it was my dad, and posted to his
just being sight that my dad had died.
He posted the obituary for what he thought was my father,
and celebrated my dad dying. So, like that's like objectively
worse on a human level. Now, he was wrong, and if he looked at
the age, I think the guy was like 80. That's the age my grandparents
Like obviously that's the age my grandparents are, so like that
doesn't make any sense.
77 Yeah, sure sure sure. But like
I'm just sitting here I'm like, "Dude, is this
I What? Why do you think that you get to say this?"
And by the way, he thought that because I talked about my stepfather
having cancer.
And so, he thought that that because this guy died of cancer
that that was my family member who I was like [__]
up about having cancer.
So, it's like
Okay. People here are laughing that Destiny through the through
entirely his own fault has not settled with Pixie, that he's
taking this to trial, and he's losing a bunch of money, right?
And so, people are laughing at him for having a hard time financially.
Now, that might be [__] up, but it's like Destiny's
actions that are leading to that. And Destiny himself is trying
to post people's obituaries hoping that it's any of his enemies'
family members that he can celebrate deaths in their
Like a different level of horrible human being, obviously, right?
But Wick sits here, and Wick is like going to polish Destiny's
for what reason? I don't know. To maintain some level of online
rapport, I guess.
It's very very
It's just gross. It's obviously gross. Now, does anybody have
the Chud clip on this? Cuz I saw the Chud clip right here. Here
it is. Here it is. Uh Did you see how much motion Stardust tweets
are getting? I'd be latching onto DGG too if I had literally
nothing else like these losers. Yeah, that's Well, that's what
they're doing, right? She knows that she can just lie about me,
and a bunch of them will spread that lie without actually being
able to defend it whatsoever because they are at their core just
lying scum. Destiny is lying scum. His audience are lying scum,
right? They They've abandoned reality entirely. They don't even
attempt to fight in reality anymore. Not even a little bit. Very
obvious. >> Obviously, Destiny is like [__]
on the event now he's out of it, kind of bitterly [__]
on it. I don't think Stardust spoke up to, and that's led to
some other thing happening. So, Stardust has talked about the
verse of victory thing and feeling undermined by it all. But
also, apparently those this This is quite funny.
The most vile people imaginable, if you mean people like you
who actively promote normalize a consent violator who lacks any
empathy and impulse control, then I surely agree. Absolute subhuman
filth, the whole lot of you.
It is honestly
shocking. It is shocking how many people are willing to get back
into the Destiny
just because they can't make a go of it themselves. Do you know
what I mean? I just would I could I would never do something
like that. I couldn't imagine going back in that in that sort
of circumstance just because
It's like particularly It's sad for Wick, but Wick at least like
needs this to eat. Stardust I don't understand because her streams
aren't successful. She is not entertaining. She's not funny or
entertaining or witty. She's actually quite dim, right? Like
she is a light bulb that soon needs to be replaced. She is very
dim. She's not intelligent. She's not witty. She's not funny.
She's not anything. She's nothing. There's nothing compelling
there whatsoever,
So, I don't get it. What are you Are you doing it for Twitter
likes?
I actually don't even get I don't get it at all. channel is It's
crazy. Right? It's like What are you doing? I thought you can't
talk to him cuz you found his behavior, you know, monstrous.
And And now you're just heading back to the plantation willingly.
Crazy to me. Absolutely nuts this is happening.
You actively harass people you dislike, including sending pictures
of dead animals to Indian women. Your boos mean nothing to me.
I've seen what you cheer. Okay, this we haven't covered this
week yet. We will go through it. All right. Where do these people
get off? You're a Destiny orbiter, bro.
Dude, what the [__] are you talking about? Bro, Destiny
is like sent pictures of talked about Oh god, he's done it again.
Yes, very obvious Rick and Morty reference in 2026. I don't even
hate Rick and Morty. It's just like you're doing it unironically.
And funniest things on Twitter. Which by the way, I don't give
a [__] about, okay? And still think they're funny
to this day.
So, it's not like I'm flipping the script on that. I still think
that was funny. But it's bizarre to me that these people are
now trying to hand wring and do the moral crusade a bit when
the person in question here is Destiny with all this he's done
in his career, you know? That's like particularly egregious in
this case. It's just the It's like I've seen what Destiny's done
to people who won't do this. Maybe that's all it is. Maybe it's
literally just fear. That Destiny's seen what's been Or sorry,
these people see what's been done to people who won't do this,
who won't just lie on his behalf, who won't like bend to whatever
he says.
Right? It could be that, maybe. Not for
but maybe for Wick, I don't know.
We'll always have that Melina super chat from Wick, okay? We'll
always have that.
Always always always.
What is it? I think we have from this week we have the substance
retweet, right? Oh, if it makes you feel better, 90% of these
accounts are probably all from the same Discord group. I don't
think Is that one from that Discord group? Is there Is there
like a clipping Discord that that person would be a part of?
They're not in any of the group chats I'm in. They're not in
anything I'm involved with. Most vile people imaginable. If you
mean people like you who actively promote normalize a consent
violator who lacks any empathy and impulse control, then I surely
agree. Absolute subhuman filth, subhuman filth, the whole lot
of you. Yeah, that's that's totally real, right? Wait, no no
no no no. Fun GG, I I have a clipping Discord,
but I don't think that person's in it. I have like a totally
different thing. But Destiny has a clipping Discord. Destiny
has like a clipping community.
Right? Everybody does this. Literally everybody has this. I don't
know why he's trying to make up the idea that this is somehow
a plot.
A clipping Discord is nothing evil. Tons of people have them.
Tons of people set up stuff for people who clip their content
so they can retweet it, so they can amplify it,
This is not a conspiracy. This is not like crazy.
I don't I don't let anybody into my who lies. So, here's where
we get into some of the Stardust stuff, okay? You actively harass
people you dislike, including sending pictures of animals to
Indian women. Your boos need not
Yes, sorry. This is the the Rick and Morty reference from Wick.
I have to show you how she signaled about this and how she's
talked about it, okay?
Because if you don't see how she signaled about it and how she's
talked about it, it is hard to understand
what the picture is. I want I want to let Stardust build the
picture up in your mind of what exactly it was, okay? Pisco is
doing a like take on all cumbers kind of thing with Wick where
he's letting anybody call in to argue his political points. Stardust
calls in to basically do a PowerPoint presentation. Now, this
PowerPoint presentation, what is the purpose of it? It is it
to explain how important cows are in Indian culture and to ask
that Substance, the clipper, be banned from Pisco's Discord for
1 week because Substance sent a picture of a cut-up cow to Stardust.
Again, no blood, like basically no gore whatsoever, no real gore
by any definition of the word. She's doing She joined Pisco's
talk about politics
to do a presentation on how she got a mean tweet sent at her
and we're coming in somewhere in the middle of this. me, right?
How else am I supposed to interpret that, right? How else am
I supposed to interpret that when somebody so mad at me is somebody
is so upset with me that they are willing to de- completely dehumanize
me to the extent that they're that it's not even just my my sensibilities
as a person of Indian it's my sensibilities as a woman, right?
Like what kind of me
>> It's my sensibilities as a woman.
And that too uses that kind of it's like it this is this is a
this is a common tactic, right?
So, so you think it's it's targeting you both because of your
ethnic background um and national background, but also because
you're a woman, right? >> I don't know if it's intentionally
targeted because I'm a woman. I just think that it's offensive
to me as a woman, you know? Okay. Uh yeah. Okay.
We believe you, for sure. Dude, you can tell from Pisco's like
demeanor the entire time she's in here, which is I think like
30 minutes, 40
Maybe even more. See, 32 is when she leaves and about 12 is when
she joins. 20 minutes. 20 minutes she does this PowerPoint presentation,
okay? She got offended and she's a woman. It offends It offends
my sensibilities as a woman. Okay.
All right. So, she then goes, "Pisco, how's this person connected
to you?" Pisco goes, "I don't know. He like clips my content
sometimes. I've retweeted
Well, would you be willing If what if I told you he participates
in your
So, what what Stardust says she doesn't know, so maybe she's
just a totally
for some DGGers was that DGG is trying to paint Pisco as like
super evil because he had a heated conversation with Hutch where
Hutch was performatively
like not understanding, misunderstanding every point Pisco was
making and Pisco got a little annoyed by the end of it and was
like trying to explain things. Hutch was just an ass the whole
time, okay? Horrible conversation from Hutch, total loser behavior,
okay? And all DGGers wanted to paint Pisco as bad because Pisco
had previously said that he didn't want to I think ban people
from his community for not liking Destiny. That was it. Right?
Cuz they say, "Well, Destiny was a 17-year-old exchange material
with 17-year-old." He didn't like that, Destiny. So, he tried
to get Pisco to change something. Pisco said, "What do you want
me to do?" And Destiny went, "Uh I don't know." "Well, I don't
know. I don't know what you What What do you want me to say?"
It's like, "Bro, you started the conversation. What do you want
me to do?" "Well, I don't
Okay? That's That's why this happened is because Stardust was
told about all this [__] because And also, this is
in January. This is 3 weeks, 4 weeks, 3 weeks after Stardust
had received the tweets. So, it's way later as well. Okay? All
right.
So, she comes in here trying to propagate this narrative that
Pisco's community is like crazy and there's all full of like
insane leftists.
By the way, she does this whole presentation, she leaves till
the very
that Substance literally apologized.
She didn't like the apology, but Substance literally apologized
and said, "I shouldn't have done this. It was about like It basically
was racist. I don't want to be that person, so my bad." Now,
not only did he apologize at the time, back 3 weeks ago when
it happened, but then she didn't like the apology, he deleted
that apology, he made a new apology that was more in line with
what she expected.
And what do we get? A couple weeks later on Twitter, Stardust
is once again trying to signal on all of this cow head [__]
okay? "Oh, you You attacked me. It was a physical attack. It
was a borderline physical attack."
It's maybe not a physical attack in how you would typically think
of it, but it is one. Uh like in my opinion, you are
crossing a a line where you are no longer doing little, you know,
mean comments, being >> no longer doing little, you know,
mean comments, being being mean to people. You are intentionally
You are trying to trigger somebody. You're trying to traumatize
somebody. That is that turns into a physical response. This is
a borderline physical attack, okay? I'm I'm I'm going to treat
it like it's a pretty big deal.
Speech is violence.
That If that's not a leftist position, I don't know what is.
Guys, this is a borderline physical attack. I'm going to treat
it like a physical attack. This Substance person is a woman beater.
Substance, now you're a woman beater, okay? Apparently you are
a woman beater. Infamously, women be women beaters like, you
know, immediately apologize for saying something offensive. Yep.
That's That's what they're infamous for, for sure.
Definitely. All right, let's uh let's keep looking. Let's keep
looking. She talks about it further on her stream. I I laughed
at her because I said the exact same thing that Chud said today.
I said it back then. Stardust used to go on and get like the
most insane racial berating happening to her just for a few
Why is she acting like this just destroyed her sensibilities?
Do you like, "Well, it's gore. Well, it's gore. Well, it's gore."
Right?
Oh, you can't say that cuz it's gore.
And she says this all the time, right? >> He didn't pick
this out of nowhere. It would be one thing if he sent me gore
by itself and it wasn't targeted. We would still find that gross,
but it wouldn't be this level. Um this wasn't like a random edgy
meme he had laying around. He knew my
He specifically sought out a mutilated cow or he had one and
he sent it directly He sent He quoted quote tweeted me because
he knew I was Indian, right? That's all he knew. Well, I think
it's a little bit worse than that because it's gore. He took
a symbol of peace, right? Um a cultural taboo, basically. Watch
It'd be like sending a sending a black person a picture of a
cross on fire.
Well, I think it's a little bit worse than that because it's
gore.
Who would have done something like that?
I just wonder who would have done something a little bit like
Why did Wick Wick was like Johnny-on-the-spot with that example
somehow?
How did How is Wick just Johnny-on-the-spot with that example?
Back to this, all right? Back to this. >> Right? It's just
gore, right? >> that cuz it's gore. It's worse than a burning
cross cuz it's gore.
uh basically I think he he you know, it's like you're sending
what is an image of peace to somebody but desecrating that, right?
Um and then obviously identity dehuman Desecrating that. Not
really desecrating that more than any butcher shop does in America
every single day.
It's the same. Now, the picture's a little bit It's the picture
is not what you'd see in an American butcher shop necessarily
unless you went in the back, but it is like literally butchering
an animal. Like I not the active process either. It is a butchered
animal that has been drained.
So, she keeps talking about how it's gore. It's gore. It's gore.
It's gore. It's gore. Guys, it's gore. Hold on, what is this
one? Stardust complaining about how it would have been offensive
if it was if she was Hindu or sorry. Imagine getting so mad at
the at a comment that you send a pic of a dead cow to someone
without checking if they're Hindu first.
Well, she's not Hindu for one. Wait, what's this What was the
Substance tweet he's deleted? Oh, wait. Wait, this isn't
Wait, this isn't implying that she's not offended by it by because
she's not Hindu. It said
Wait. Wait.
Is this literally implying that oh, that didn't work on me because
I'm not even Hindu? I think that's literally what she's saying
here, no? On On the day it was sent, she says, "Oh, you didn't
even check if I was Hindu before you sent that, so you look silly."
Wow. I didn't even know about this tweet.
Well, that sure is silly. That sure makes everything look silly.
Dude.
Okay, hold on. Hold on.
Now, she says to me, okay?
She's saying to me, you know,
"Perhaps you should shut the [__] up since you justified
people sending me dead severed animals' heads animal heads just
a few weeks ago knowing it was racially targeted."
No, I didn't. Explaining why something
is not the same
justifying it. So, Stardust was going in on Cherry and I think
Destiny retweeted her and Substance said, "Oh, you're like a
vile you're like a vile you. You're gross." And she was like,
"Oh, did I hurt your feelings?" And Substance responded with
the picture, okay? That was how it went. And I explained that
listen, if you're going to be like if you're going to say, "Oh,
did I hurt your feelings?" online, you probably should expect
somebody to come back and go, "Oh, did I hurt your feelings?"
to do the thing that offends you, that would offend you most,
and go, "Did I hurt your feelings?"
Doesn't mean it's okay. I said don't do it. In fact, I timed
him out from my Discord. So, she's just lying here, right? She's
just trying to use this thing. She's swinging this thing around
like a cudgel
over and over again.
Now, why is she doing that? I wouldn't necessarily have
like a problem with her doing this if we actually did just like
say, "Oh, no, we're going to send you more you stupid bitch."
But that's not what happened. I said that was bad. I said it
was racist.
I said that was wrong to do.
Substance apologized twice.
And here's what you get for apologizing twice. Here's what you
get for saying, "Oh, you shouldn't have done that." and apologizing,
right? She keeps bringing it up as if And by the way, totally
misunderstanding my stream where I was making fun of her, but
not for being the target of a racial attack.
She just totally misunderstands.
It's sad. She's obviously not even really offended. I think so.
That's That was another point I made. Yes, she's obviously not
even offended. Yes, I know I timed you out for a week as well,
Substance. Yes, I did.
Now, without further ado, I'm going to pull up the
You start to get like a picture of just like she says I'm a sick
telling Substance, "Hey, that was bad." and timing him out. I
did the thing By the way, I did the thing Pisco wouldn't do.
I did the thing Pisco opted not to do. I timed him out for the
exact period Stardust requested.
Right? It is schmoolie behavior. Yes, it is schmoolie behavior.
Stardust is engaging She's got a little bit of Is this a Is this
a downstream symptom of overall JN?
It might just be. It may just be. And it's just it like what
is the point of engaging in any How How do you engage in good
faith with these people when this is the way they are? Like how
can I engage when I did the things that were correct, that you
should do?
And she keeps doing this. Just for I guess DGG retweets or
And she's spreading lies, like openly spreading lies. And we
will prove it shortly, okay?
I can explain to you exactly how she is dumb, exactly how she
doesn't understand what's going on. Okay? We will do all of it.
But with all this being said, all right, we we keep talking about
all of this and
Do I try to go to her responding to me and looking at this? I
don't think so. I think we'll just go to show the actual tweet,
okay? Now, Stardust, if if you're looking, look away because
I'm going to show this for my stream, okay? I'm going to show
this for my stream.
All right, look away if this offends you. If you are not okay
with seeing a head of a cow, look away. But this is not gore,
this is not anything like that, okay?
That's what it is. It's like out on a table in a market. You
can sort of see that there's some muscle tissue here.
But it's like it's just it's just what would be out at a Chinese
wet market if you're selling this stuff, okay?
Now, as much as that could be like something that's weird to
send somebody, it's certainly not like a physical attack. It's
certainly not anything disgusting. It's like, "Oh, that's weird.
That's a weird picture to send." Like I guarantee you if I Google
butchered cow, I will find 100 more offensive pictures immediately.
I will find far more offensive, far more disgusting, far more
depraved pictures instantly, right?
This is not anywhere near the level of "Oh, it's months later
now and she is still traumatized by it." It is unreasonable at
this point. Again,
racist attack, absolutely. But the idea that this because it's
gore, it's somehow massively traumatizing. Bro, you would see
this at any random wet market in any non-Western country.
Absolutely. Have you ever been to Hong Kong? Have you ever seen
a wet market there? It's gross.
But it's just like this, okay? So, again, not endorsing, just
explaining that it's clear it's
obviously clear.
Right? It's obviously clear that this is not a physical attack,
that this is not something insane, that she's not that up by
it, okay? If she wasn't that up by Ethan Ralph and Nick Fuentes
and all of these racists constantly
attacking her on the basis of her religion and appearance, then
is she really that up by a picture?
Oh, that's gore. It's barely anything.
Come on, man. By the way, still I'm still saying don't send that
stuff. Don't do that. It's just obviously performative. It's
obviously totally performative. She looks absurd.
And I I said don't do it. Substance apologized and she's still
going to pretend that this was the worst thing she's had done
to her on the internet. Why? Well, it's basically all very
It's all about the groups. It's all about who sent it and what
they do, right? That is why she's mad about it. She's not mad
about it because it's gross. She's not mad about it because it's
racist. She's not mad about it because it's demeaning. She's
not mad about it for any of these reasons. She's mad about it
because Substance clips Queen Man, Substance clips me, Substance
clips Hasan, right? That's what she's mad about. That's what
she's actually upset about and nothing else. And it's
and it's like depraved. And now she's like actually straight
up lying about which is the other weird thing, saying that like
I said, "Oh, Substance should have said it was a threat of physical
And I I can explain to you how that happened, but it's going
to be it's it's going to be a little bit, okay? Let's make sure
we get to all of the clips here from this. Oh, she tweets something
else out here, okay?
And again, we'll just say the same exact same thing to Stardust
as we said before. Why you shouldn't take anything Jstark says
seriously. By the way, this is all Why is she getting this upset?
I don't Can anybody tell me why she's getting this upset over
me pointing out that Destiny lied about Supreme being a
And Destiny lied
or sorry, Destiny didn't lie, but he
non-consensually Pixie. Why is she upset about that? Why? Why
Why is she mad about that?
Again, as Luna Box's editor, that seems really weird, no? Didn't
Luna Box like fully support Pixie? Wasn't he obviously saying
that this was the case? What did I say there that offended her?
Why would she come out and start attacking me personally for
making a clear point that hey, this is why Progressive Victory
is probably not fans of Destiny. Can anybody Can anybody think
of why? I I
I can't think of any logical reason she would be upset with this
other than she just wants clout. And she's at me and/or Queen
Man. And also also she's Gilded Poos' editor, the anti-Muslim
racist. Oh, damn.
DNC justified and defended someone sending me gore of a severed
cow head knowing it was a racist attack on the basis that he
apologized and I acknowledges it was a acknowledged that it was
a racist attack and never justified ever.
I explained
while saying it was wrong. If you explain and say it's still
wrong to do, that's not a justification.
It's an
Okay? If I just If I just explained only
and left it ambiguous, then maybe you could say this, but I didn't
do that.
He's desperate for positive female attention will manipulate
to get it. What is this based on? Everybody is trying to imply
that Dude, it's so crazy. To these people, I like met Cherry
because of the audio recordings and I formed a relationship after
covering the content.
All of these people have totally rewritten this fact the fact
that we did a stream together for months
full-time for months
that we were friends for over a year. I'm sorry, there are If
you all you want is female attention, there are far easier ways
to do it. And then she calls me fat, which like, okay, mirror
post. I Okay. Again,
um the picture they they say is me, not me, but again, I'd have
to I'd have to like fully dox myself to There's like a reason
I can't I'm not going to like be any more clear than that.
But I I literally can't get further into it. It's It's a problem.
regardless, let's say I am for the sake of argument. I'll just
I'll just agree to it.
why would that
Do you think the reason people didn't take you seriously, Stardust,
is because you were fat?
Because you are fat? Do you think that's why people don't take
you seriously? I've got news for you, it's got nothing to do
with your appearance, which is
It has nothing to do with why people don't take you seriously.
Lot of ugly people in the world, lot of fat people in the world,
get taken seriously. That has nothing to do with why nobody thinks
you're a serious person
at all.
It is your IQ.
It is just your IQ. You
You are dumb. You are incapable of making cogent or coherent
arguments at all. You are embarrassing.
Anyway,
anyway, anyway, anyway.
Okay, so those were her two tweets about me, all right.
I basically say, "Okay." I literally don't even I don't even
try to fight her on anything else. I just go,
"Okay, but do you disagree that this is likely why PV doesn't
like Destiny?" And she says, "Okay, but do you disagree that
this is likely why PV doesn't like
Because the runner of social media accounts says otherwise. Okay,
the So, illiterate on top of everything else, very unfortunate.
Very unfortunate that she can't follow basic sentence structure.
Do you disagree that this is likely why PV doesn't like Destiny?
Because the runner of social media accounts says
Yeah, okay.
Now, hold on. Let me go and find the Let me go find this tweet
again real The Now, she takes it quite literally, right? She
takes this tweet literally. This tweet right here, she takes
it
Jealousy, thy name is what's his name again? So, Destiny's the
PV event.
She She thinks this is serious. She
that when they tweeted this, they actually don't know who Destiny
is. Despite the fact that Destiny was publicly associated with
the
Like in her mind, she's like, "No, they actually don't know who
he is at all."
Are we Are we really pretending this? This seems a little No?
Isn't this really dumb? She
She took this literally. Well, actually they said they
The social media account says otherwise. By the way, this guy
comes in and I truly truly remarkable stuff.
All right. I publicly refuted Steven's comment about Supreme
and directly asked for a public retraction because it was false
and Supreme was a co-worker who I still hold and accept in exceptionally
high regard. That said, the ongoing behavior from Progressive
Victory has been entirely unprofessional.
What's this? This tweet is
Why is this tweet unprofessional? What What about this tweet
is unprofessional? The guy's literally It's responding to
their organization. They're They're organization is literally
being trashed by him. He is a former person. He's them. How is
it In what universe is this unprofessional? Organizations are
catty on Twitter all the time. It's actually wild to call it
unprofessional.
Okay? But anyway, I do believe that Stardust just says, "Yeah,
I'm not entirely aware with of the Supreme of the stuff with
Supreme."
Okay. Well, I can't even I can't even go into all the stuff with
Supreme. I can't even go into it. But suffice to say, the original
comments, not even close to not even really scratching the surface
on the Destiny's done to Supreme, okay? Over this. But you wouldn't
look into it because you are a
You are a useful
idiot, okay? Why would you look into it? Just defend Destiny.
Just go, "Oh, why would these people be mad at Destiny?" With
no idea of what you're talking about again. By the way, when
she joins when she's trying to defend herself with the Peacekeeper
thing, she goes, "Oh, I didn't know anything about the stuff
with like Destiny's community. I didn't know about any of that."
Why don't you know anything ever?
Why do you get Why do you think you go into a situation and your
your cope every single time is, "Oh, I didn't know about any
of that. I don't have any idea about any of that."
She's feigning ignorance, clearly. I think she's probably feigning
ignorance is probably what's happening there,
Probably. Probably probably.
let me see here. Where are we going after this?
Oh, dude, she went in on Helbent, too, which was weird.
And all of it is just not knowing anything, right? She just keeps
spreading this lie over and over again. If you're someone who
justified people sending me gore of severed head of a severed
cow head a month ago a month ago, I'm not going to take your
opinion seriously on whether is a slur, okay? Like what? I don't
have you blocked. You could just tweet at me. You could just
quote tweet me. You just tweet at me.
I don't have you blocked. You could just do whatever you you
do that.
Right there. Again, didn't justify literally said don't do it.
Repeatedly, over and over again. Okay.
Here, I'll I'll pull up the Helbent tweets here cuz she just
sent me them.
So, Helbent then messages Stardust. We're going to get into some
of the actual claims she was making, by the Okay, we'll get into
her vod and laughing at how stupid she is. All
Can't believe they would devalue a pest contributions like this.
Bro, you can keep quiet like half the people Bro, you can keep
quiet. So, again, not going to tangibly respond to anything.
Just going to say, "Actually, you you do bad things somewhere
else." No tangible response. Nothing at all. Just running and
and going to like attack people. I What is your purpose, man?
Yeah, she's got no way to argue the substance of anything. Like
she's actually just worthless as a person.
Worthless as an entity on the internet. I don't know. Be like
a faceless editor, man. You You got nothing to say. You got nothing
to say at all. Bro, you can keep quiet like half the people you
sweep for DM minors or did worse. Uninterested in your opinion.
I said what? Huh? I think she's I think she's talking about Moral,
probably.
What What is the sweeping for that? But he was definitely flirting
with the 17-year-old in his DMs when he was 21, 22, 23, somewhere
in there.
Is that the sweeping? Like accurately ex like explaining the
behavior?
That's sweeping.
Why would that be sweeping? I'm I could literally say what happened.
Well, I'm sorry. I don't remember the age anymore. Oh, Stardust
got very mad
Dude, uh Wick Wick did this. Helbent basically said, "Actually,
that's
And then Stardust said, "I suspected she hated my ass for a while,
then saw this and clicked her profile and oh, blocked." Wow.
Stardust had blocked her and then unblocked her, I believe, okay?
And so, messaged her and said, "Sorry, I shouldn't have blocked
you for that. Was uncalled for I shouldn't have blocked you.
That was uncalled for. I'm just irritated the PV account is being
run into the ground, IMO, and I'd never want to work them as
with them as a creator
Because they're distan they're distancing from somebody who's
violated some of their employees?
Who Who violated multiple employees? Is that it? Is that all?
Watchog, back to the cave with you. Hold on, I need to pull up
my Kick dashboard to ban you. Go back to the cave, you loser.
All you do is exist on the internet. You have no job. You have
no prospects in life.
I would tell you what to do, but I think you know what to do.
You know what to do. You know how to You know how to You know
what to do. Just be real. You know what to do.
You know. See, we're getting better. We're getting better. We're
not We're going to We're totally TOS compliant. When we go to
YouTube, we're totally TOS compliant, okay? It's going to happen.
It's totally happening. All right. So, all right. All right.
Uh actually, never mind. I saw some of your tweets. So, then
he pulls this up. Actually, never mind. I saw some of your tweets.
We should We probably shouldn't talk, lmao. Good luck. Maybe
we'll talk at some point far in the future.
How You said this was okay? You said this was okay? No. No.
Quick Schmooly update. Well, we'll save it for after the segment,
Ryle. Send it to me after the segment.
We're in a seggy. Don't interrupt the seggy with extraneous details.
Now, let's go to some of these Stardust bits, all right? When
I was asking about like, "What do we even do? How do we even
handle these people being like dishonest all the
How do we even handle this, right?
I don't know.
But here's what Stardust said. Stardust said things would be
okay
>> clear, [snorts] what what what are we what are we asking
Pisco for here? I would ask that until this person like makes
a more decent like apology that they be outed from the community.
So, be outed from the community.
By the way, right after this, Substance did a better apology.
Okay? So, you've seen all the commotion surrounding a post I
made against Stardust, tweets from Star, and I felt I should
address the situation. For those not aware of the details, on
this past Christmas Eve, I noticed Star had made a post taking
him and Cherry stated finding faith through God for her was a
blessing that was helping her grow as a person and get through
the trials and trauma she has experienced. And Star's response
was, "Diabolical rebrand, TBH." Another person who became aware
of Star's post because Destiny reposted it responded to Star
saying that she was essentially polishing Destiny's image, to
which Star responded that her problems with Cherry predates all
of this and that she's allowed to be mean on the internet and
that Destiny has nothing to do with her post. This is where I
responded to to Star initially saying, "Yes, Stardust, you are
in fact allowed to be a petty, vile, vindictive co-main if you
want to be. Truly brilliant stuff here, I must say."
Okay, so awesome. Which was a criticism to her saying the obvious
being that she's allowed to be mean, which I felt was avoiding
the point that she was taking a low blow over an old feud at
someone who is trying to leave this space with some grace and
newfound
Star replies to me saying, "Boo hoo, I hurt your sensitive feelings."
To which I responded with a quote tweet that featured a dismembered
cow, which was my messed up way of showing I'm allowed to be
mean on the internet, too. But the rationale I had shouldn't
be taken to minimize the effect my depraved post was intended
to have on Stardust. It was an unnecessary disgusting escalation
that did in fact have racist undertones being that it targeted
her Indian background and a symbol that is revered and as holy
to many from India, as well as this being off the back of anti-Indian
hatred that is rising and I knew she had concerns about that.
The nature of the photo being gore, while it wasn't my intent
to menace or threaten any kind of physical violence, was intended
to shock and disturb Stardust and obviously upset her. It was
unequivocally wrong to target Star in such a manner and attempt
By the way, look. This is This is literally every single element
that she wanted. It is giving her everything she wanted and it
wasn't enough. None of it was enough for her. None of it was
enough for Wick. None of it is enough for any of these people,
right?
This is exactly what you should be looking for to go, "Yeah,
that seems heartfelt. That seems like real and we're all going
to move on."
No? Is that Is that not precisely what it should be? Like what
do you even do? If this isn't enough at all, what do you what
do you need? This is why you don't give in to people who manipulate
situations like this. That's how it's starting to seem, right?
There's just no reason to ever apologize to these people. Like
to Stardust, to anybody who's doing this kind of thing. Who won't
If you have a clear double standard in the level of behavior
that you expect out of people. And this is This is just everybody
who defends Destiny. They have an obvious double standard. They
will apply a totally different standard to you than the one they
apply to Destiny. And as so long as that is the case, never apologize
to them. Never Never give in like this, right? For as long as
that's the case. If they want to operate operate in the world
of human beings, then that's fine. But if they're going to operate
in that world and they're going to defend him,
Hold them to that standard.
You didn't want the apology, she wanted the weapon. Exactly.
Exactly, that's what she did, right?
She just wants to use it as a cudgel. She's not interested in
getting justice. She's not interested in anything. She wanted
a cudgel the whole time.
And it's obvious now, right? And it's embarrassing. Should be
embarrassing for them.
Probably not. I If Stardust was capable of shame, she would probably
been off the internet a long time ago.
So, it was unequivocally wrong to target Star in such a manner
and attempt to make her feel lesser than simply for the background
she's from. She and others should be afforded the dignity of
not being attacked for immutable traits on their background they
were born into and rather instead should be criticized for their
conduct and behavior. Independent of those things, I independent
of those things. Independent of their
Yeah, and conduct and behavior independent of their immutable
traits. I don't necessarily agree with trying to attach my conduct
directly to other communities and or creators, but I empathize
with the idea that in a space even I myself have criticized of
that in a space even I myself have criticized of not doing enough
to hold their own accountable that understandably Stardust out
of frustration would seeks out some accountability for a horrendous
wrong that was taken against her. So, I want to cut through all
the noise of the drama and I do want to genuinely apologize again
to Stardust for trying to make her feel inferior and attacking
her based on her heritage and background in a truly atrocious
manner. No one should be made to feel unworthy on that basis.
So, this is this is what I said at the time, BBPoison.
I think that this is literally the advice I gave him, but I'm
a little annoyed that the advice I gave him that like now they're
still just going to keep going. The advice I gave him was you're
basically apologizing for violating your own
You're not apologizing because they are immoral. Stardust is
a totally unprincipled hack. She's a [__]
She is actual human scum, okay? Actual human scum.
So, you don't apologize to her because she's human scum. She
is not worthy of an apology. You apologize for violating your
own principles, for violating your own morals. You don't treat
people who are total degenerate scum like Stardust like that
kind of scum because you don't believe in doing that, okay? So,
while she is in fact and not based on immutable characteristics,
but on the content of her character, she is total scum, you don't
do this this immutable character attack anyway cuz it's against
your principles. Is she that bad? Yeah, she has no principles
whatsoever.
I find I find Sorry, when I say scum, I'm like worthless. Like
not not worthy of anything. Not of value. Presents nothing of
value. Gives not entertainment. Gives not wisdom. Gives not anything
to this planet and will be incapable of doing so for the rest
of her wretched existence, okay? That's what I mean. I don't
mean like, oh, she's, you know, cutting people up in her basement.
Yeah.
Anyway, okay, we keep going. Keep going. We keep going. We keep
going. All right. All right. All right. We are looking at
What are we looking at next? We are looking at I think we might
go to the my one clip next. Yeah? Oh, so she basically said she
wanted the apology. Apology wasn't enough. Now, we can look back
at
not this tweet. Not this.
We go up to here, okay? So, where does she say She says something
encouraging people to threaten me. Encouraging people to say
it was me. Encouraging people to threaten me. That's not what
happened, okay?
And I don't know if this clip perfectly illustrates it, but I
do believe it does. So, this is what she's referring to in her
whole thing, okay?
Saying it was me. Encouraging people to say it was me. This is
me laughing when you say when she hinted at the idea that it
might be physical violence, okay?
She hinted at that it might be physical violence and I'm like,
how is it a hint of physical violence? Are you self-inserting
as the cow?
That was the joke, right? And we laughed and we laughed and we
laughed and then we moved on.
That's not encouraging people to say it was you. It's literally
laughing at you having a histrionic moment and saying that it
was you. That it is a threat of physical violence. That it's
attacking you as a woman. That men who threaten physical violence
are disgusting scum.
All of these things, okay? That's what we're laughing at.
It's like, bro, it's a cow. You're not a cow. Are you self-inserting
as the cow? Okay. Now, we'll listen to this bit right here. >> foresight
that when he posted that tweet to go, "Actually, this is because
I think you're a cow and I'm threatening you physically. It's
not racist at all." >> Oh, he's not saying he's not denying
that it was racially undertone, okay? He's just saying that Substance
should have said, "Actually, this isn't racist. It's because
you're a cow and I'm making a physical threat of violence against
you." Again, that
No, that's taking it literally.
Uh this I might have to go find the timestamp. So, what I'm doing
here is she says, "Well, I wasn't trying to do anything to Pisco.
Like I wasn't trying to do that." I started talking about how
the effect like the outcome of what you're doing is something
that you should take into account. The outcome of what you're
is with Pisco. And so, even if Substance said something like,
"Well, if you physically You replay it from the beginning? I
can replay it from the beginning. So, I'm just giving you the
context so we can go back and watch it and validate this. But
I'm saying even if Substance had said, "Well, I'm not doing this
racistly. I'm just threatening you physically."
That doesn't mean it's not racist. It is still a racist attack,
right? Him changing the him changing what he's saying, right?
Knowing that he exists in these communities, knowing that he's
aware of the lore, it doesn't actually change that he obviously
knows you're Indian and knows how Indians view cows, right?
like him saying, "Well, I didn't want to do that."
It doesn't make a difference, right? The The words are totally
dis like disconnected from the actions. The actions are he's
doing a racist action and it's probably disconnected from his
thoughts, very likely, okay? That's the point I'm trying to make
here. Substance would have had the foresight that when he posted
that tweet to go, "Actually, this is because I think you're a
cow and I'm threatening you physically. It's not racist at all."
>> Oh, he's not saying he's not denying that it was racially
undertone, okay? He's just saying that Substance should have
said, "Actually, this isn't racist. It's because you're a cow
and I'm making a physical threat of violence against you." Again,
that would um Nope. That would not be better. Jstock.
That would not be better. That would actually give me
reason to like escalate the issue further. Nope. This is all
within the context of an analogy, but she tends to she tends
to pause and ramble about nothing and totally forget where she
was. She doesn't have the ability to like she's one of those
people with no no memory. No like short-term memory, okay? She
got no RAM up in the brain. So, when she goes and she pauses
a clip, she loses all context in the thing she was watching.
It's actually something I'm good at. You probably don't notice
it cuz I'm so great at it, but I will always remember where I
left off in the conversation essentially, okay? I'm super good
at that. I can go on a 5-minute ramble and remember where I was.
I can let somebody else go on a 5-minute ramble and remember
where they started, okay? Actually, unique talent of mine.
Stardust though, no such no such luck. So, she loses the fact
that she is in that I am describing an analogy. I'm doing an
analogy. I'm trying to I'm trying to use a comparison, okay?
She loses it there. that one you're calling me a cow, you're
saying it's a a threat to physical violence and now you're denying
that there's a racial undertone to this. I'd like to make it
clear it wasn't racist.
So, you can see this oh this cool your system guy down here
says Oh, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. We've got this cool your
system guy says he gets it. Not to be racist, but that that caveat
doesn't mean anything. Not to do this thing, but it's obvious
what the analogy is. I'm trying to explain that you saying it's
not racist doesn't mean it's not racist. To to basically criticize
Stardust for saying, "Well, I wasn't trying to do anything to
Okay, but you are.
So, what do I say there?
I don't actually wish that. I'm just aiming along. But Jesus
Christ, man. Like you can't just say, "Well, this isn't racist."
And it's now not racist,
Well, surely for Stardust's sake, when she's saying that I'm
obviously saying that you should physically attack her, when
I'm encouraging people to physically attack her, obviously she's
sitting there. We're watching her watch the content. We're watching
this fat watch the content, okay? With her stupid penguin nose,
and she is pretending she doesn't understand.
Or she's actually not understanding. I can't tell which. You
couldn't do that. You couldn't do it. You can't say, "Well, actually,
this isn't racist." And then post something that's racist intentionally
and then be saved. Like it's it's over right there. That's why
she will not post the clip. That's why she will not post evidence
at all, okay?
That is literally why she won't post evidence. Why she is just
sitting here pretending not to under cuz she probably went back
after she said all this, she almost certainly went back and looked
and realized, "Oh, I'm a right?" She She tweeted all this [__]
I said post the clip. She goes She goes AFK and then she comes
back and she just reiterates that it happened. No, it didn't.
No, it didn't. It's there clear as day. Now, the funny thing
about this,
The funny thing about this is she had another clip.
All right. So, she took it She took this analogy thing literally.
It was not meant literally. I literally even for the sake of
clips actually point out that I do not mean this literally, okay?
Now, this would all This is all already funny. This is already
indicative of how intelligent she is. But it's really the cherry
on top is what she says, I believe about 90 seconds before this,
Where's this Where's this I think somebody sent this to me. Yeah.
Yeah, they did. Okay. That This makes it so much better. Hold
on.
But oh what you just have to take everything literally? You know,
that's not a sign of of intelligence and you're calling me the
dumb one. I think
Um you know, taking everything literally isn't smart and you're
calling me the dumb one.
Little 707, hold on. Where is it in the VOD the previous clip
we were looking at? Hold on. Oh [__] Not the not
the right one. One second, let me pull the previous clip up.
This one. Where is this in the VOD?
Pause again. Give me the time.
708. So it's literally 1 minute across the VOD, okay? Sorry,
30 seconds away in the VOD. In 30 seconds she's about to take
my analogy literally and totally fall and totally fall into the
exact thing she's criticizing, which she I'm not doing by the
way.
She's she's about to do the exact thing. She literally says,
"It's not smart to take things literally. I'm I'm a lot smarter
than you." And then take something literally and looks like a
You can't make it up.
But oh what you just have to take everything literally? You know,
that's not a sign of of intelligence and you're calling me the
dumb one. I think between the two of us, Jay Stahli, I think
you would be surprised, okay? If you're taking every No. No,
I wouldn't be surprised at all. Between the two of us, who's
the more intelligent person? Nope. Not even a little bit. >> things
that literally, you're probably not too smart.
Oh, if you take things that literally, you're probably not too
smart. >> too smart.
Oh, hold on. Between the two of us, Jay Stahli, I think you would
be surprised,
If you're taking everything's that literally, you're probably
not too smart. Wow.
Wow. Little eye pops out? Oh my god. I am only like I preface
that presentation by saying that this is not an indictment on
his community and not an indictment of him. I I very much said
that. So I think that
Well, I wish I wish Substance would have had the foresight that
when he posted
Connect it right there. I'm listening. I'm trying to Listen,
you could maybe even say the analogy is like a little ham-fisted,
but it's clearly an analogy. It is clearly disavowed like as
a little little If you are see if you're hearing this like literally,
no, it's not literal. I don't mean it, okay? That's how close
it is in time. tweet to go, "Actually, this is because I think
you're a cow and I'm fighting you physically. It's not racist
at all." I wish he had the foresight to make it clear it wasn't
racist. I I I You can pretend again. Like you can say, "Well,
this isn't racist and it's now not racist, right?" You could
Well, we can pretend we can pretend. Wait, what is this argument
that he's making here? Is he actually trying to say it wasn't
racist that it was She's so You are not smart enough to do this.
You are so stupid.
You are so embarrassingly stupid.
Why are you trying to do this? Why are you trying to make content?
You're not funny, you're not intelligent, you're not interesting.
It's sad to watch. It's a total
He sent me the cow because he thinks I'm a cow. Is that really
what he's trying to say here? But when he posted that tweet to
Looking like a Goomba. By the way, I told Stardust this when
she got really angry at me. She hates me for hanging out with
Queenman. I literally constantly would tell Queenman, "I'm not
going to make fun of Stardust on my stream. I'm not going to
do that. We're not doing that today." I did this for months on
end. I told Queenman, "No, you know, blah blah blah. I don't
I don't think we should do
And she still attached me to it. And then she tries to make appearance
attacks on me by the way, which
trust me. I I just don't understand where
The confidence is crazy. I'm just going to put it out there.
Brooke is like a 100 times better looking than Stardust. It's
not close.
If you guys both lose weight, Brooke has a chance of being attractive.
I'm sorry. It's not close, Stardust. It's not close. And I'm
sure [clears throat] she'll hate hearing
I Why are there all these Queenman tweets? What the
How did How did Queenman What Why is Queenman doing this? What
the man?
Why do you keep doing it?
It's crazy.
I feel like sometimes I don't tweet aggressively about stuff
because I feel like some level of well, I don't know 100% that
I'm correct on everything. And then I find out other people are
just like they have no idea what they're talking about at all.
They have no clue whatsoever. They have no
command of the world, excuse me, of the world or the information
in front of them whatsoever.
They've got nothing. And they just tweet confidently about
She says this happened. It didn't happen at all. You got made
fun of and you're on Twitter like virtue signaling about it.
For for like the likes
from a predator's community.
A predator you disavowed, but I know what this is. I We all know
what this is and it's fine.
This isn't This isn't going to work for these people. I'm sorry
to say, all right? It's not going to work. It's not a good long-term
strategy, but
she pretended she was barely associated with. That's what I find
so funny. People like I know there were people who were like
kind of deranged and would like accuse them of association, people
like Stardust or Wick. And they go, "No, I don't I don't do anything
with them. I don't like them. I know I'm not around." And then
the second they think it's like possibly okay to go back and
hang out with them, they're immediately they immediately just
crawl back. Yes. And And like if facts changed, I would maybe
understand the crawling back, but no facts changed.
Zero facts from when they disavowed have changed. It was still
shared non-consensually. It still is like four or five women
we know about who had their material shared non-consensually.
Right? The tapes. And that's without even getting into the non-consensual
recording stuff. They all disavowed over And they're all going
back even though it is essentially admitted to. And on top of
that, he added in doxing a bunch of your friends and former former
friends, former like streamer colleagues. He doxed a bunch of
them. Oh, and he tries to [__] with Pisco
What are these people doing? And by the way, a bunch of his
totally disgusting degenerate
equally consent
violating fans are in comments trying to ask her to confirm and
say, "Oh no, no, everything he said was correct. He needed to
go after those people." And all the lies he said that were explicitly
disavowed by Not So Erudite, by PV's employees, by I believe
Sam Seder's mom himself, I think, though I don't remember that
for 100%.
All of the
These These people just lie and they'll say, "No, no, no, Destiny
was right about that actually. Destiny was right about that."
Disgusting. Okay.
Dick hers. Dick hers. Dick hers. Dick hers. Talk to Gilded Poo.
Now, we didn't go through the whole Stardust stream, but Gilded
Poo is the person she edits for and that's basically her number
one chatter, the person who chats most in her stream, okay? Well,
I say that there's like two Kathy alts. They probably chat more
than Gilded Poo, but I'm saying actual person who likes her.
She does talk to Kathy a lot when she streams. When she streams,
Kathy is the person she talks to the most.
And I think she knows I think she has like some underlying feeling
that this chatter is making fun of her. Like when Gunboxed is
in your your YouTube chat, right? That's your boss calling him
Gunboxed is making fun of the Loner Unboxed channel, that is
Spider's channel, right? But this person his name is Gunboxed
and Stardust just chats with them because she's looking for like
any any hope.
And she just tells herself like a little bit in the back of her
head, "No, that might be like maybe that's like somebody who
does just like me. Maybe they just don't like Loner Box and maybe
they're like cool with me." No. No, they're not cool with you.
No, they're not cool with you at all.
They're making fun of you basically the whole time. Dick hers.
We got a Dick hers stream? I think I got a Dick hers VOD here.
Hold
>> Yeah. I was Okay. very deathly sick.
Oh, I wanted to talk to Gilded Poo at this time, too.
I wanted to talk to Gilded Poo at this time. I was like, "Hey,
you seem to think I've like got major issue What do you think
is the problem here?"
Oh, by the way, I also I held off of commenting on Stardust's
appearance like for so long. And at this point, she's commenting
on mine and
commenting on other people's. So I I feel like it's, you know,
it's fair game
I I let her strike first. All right? I think it's totally fine
for me to do that at this point. No? I think so. I think so.
I I let her get the first hit.
It's not a problem. >> And in her chat Un- unfortunately
though, another unfortunate fact is,
>> I'm also able to critique her points.
So the problem is, right? I'm probably going to spend a lot more
time doing that. Like actually critiquing her points instead
of just going after like her appearance.
Or actually critiquing anyone's points that they're going to
make. I have the I I'm I'm cursed with the intellectual capacity
just argue the points.
And be be capable of doing so. That's unfortunate, man.
I was very deathly sick and in in her chat I I do vaguely remember
seeing your chats pop up and I thought they were very um I don't
know. Out of character. I think you seem to be like harshly condemning
sending somebody material related to animals to be able
>> So I think is the story here that Gilded Poo sent like
zoophile content to somebody? Am I getting that correct? I think
I heard that, but I need to I need to make sure I got this correct.
Did he play Did he send it to somebody? Is this a thing? Was
it drawn? Was it drawn or was it real? Drawn or real? Drawn or
real?
Drawn or real? Drawn or real? Somebody needs to let me know.
Drawn or real right now. Drawn or real? Real? Are we sure? Are
we sure about that? It's real? It was real?
The whole time it was real? That is a proboscis monkey in this
case. Correct. >> Yeah, no. I wasn't I wasn't like condemning
it. I was Oh, drawn by hand. Okay, so so drawn
Okay, drawn.
Interesting. animals to be able to clip
Yeah, no. [clears throat] I wasn't
I wasn't like condemning it. I was I think it was mildly hypocritical
for a progressive to do. That was like the extent of my point
of view on that. Um but [clears throat] aside from well if assuming
it was meant to be racially motivated, that is.
Uh which I mean it kind of seems that was the you know, the punchline.
But not that I care. I'm just saying that it's hypocritical.
I mean is it racially motivated? When you call Aiden a is that
racially motivated cuz you hate It's edgy. >> you hate
Aiden and it's a way to be able to get under his skin, right?
It's like racially with the idea that it's like I don't know.
Like actually I can you're right. You know what I mean? No, you're
So, these people every every single one of these people is a
level one
piggy from the big bad wolf, okay? They're like building their
houses out of straw. The big bad wolf barely even got a puff.
Ain't even huffin' and puffin' and the house collapses
every single time. Like these people have no foundation. There
is nothing there.
They're a bunch of straw house piggies, okay? They got nothing.
Literally Hey, don't you think it's like weird that you're even
commenting? Like you sort of do exactly this kind of thing. Right?
You sent You sent like a somebody being by an animal to somebody
else a drawn picture of this. And not only that you also make
racist jokes. Where is your criticism coming from? Yeah, the
wolf has asthma and it's still terrible. It's like a 90-year-old
wolf and the house still falls apart. Dickish barely pushes it
all and immediately is like, "Yeah, I Yeah, I I really I can't
criticize here, man." I can't criticize. >> Racially Racially
motivated is a little too strong of a phrase. I just mean like
edgy. Like like that that's what I'm getting at. Like but
but but no. Like and that and that I think is fine so long as
you know
>> My edgy humor is fine. Everyone else's edgy humor, that's
up, guys. You know, the person doing it is consistent about it,
which Substance doesn't seem to be that consistent about it.
So since he apologized, which he I don't think he should have
either, but you I mean I don't think that it should have been
I don't think he should have apologized cuz he's only been raked
over the coals harder, right? I don't know why she's going this
hard. I I don't think that's a good idea.
You're one of the people who gassed her up. You're in the chat
gassing her up, gilded poo. What the
Now you're going to abandon Stardust completely? You're going
to go, "Oh, I don't know why she's doing this actually. I've
got no idea why she's going this hard, why she's pretending this
is such a huge thing."
No shot. >> In fact, that's a dumb idea.
Well, I mean she's not really like going hard. So I mean just
take a look what she's saying at Jstark. I think you win the
screenshot real quick. Yeah, I That's what I'm saying. I don't
I don't think this tweet should exist.
Yeah, he was in her chat the whole stream saying, "Yeah, this
is really disgusting. These people are total pieces of shit."
Why are you validating all the dumb [__] she was
saying in her chat and now showing up on a Dicker stream to go,
"Oh, I think it's really dumb for her to make a big deal out
of this." Oh, I think it'd be really stupid for her to make a
big What the Just period. I I think she should drop it and let
it go.
Well, it's not dropping it and letting it go. It's like it's
like lying, right? It's like lying about somebody else. So she
said about Jstark that he continuously justified and defended
somebody sending me gore of a severed cow head knowing that it
was a racist attack. He said that the person should have said
the cow was me.
Three question marks?
He's desperate for positive female attention and will manipulate
to get it.
I mean those are just lies about Jstark, right? So >> stream
that she did. She knows that these are lies. Oh, and go back
to the other the other tweet real quick. So
>> Dickish, you forgot the part where you're supposed to
say the thing where it's like, "No, he's not fat." Dickish, you
forgot the this last lie. Dickish, Dickish, you missed a lie?
Hey Dickish, you missed a lie?
What the So the gore would not call it gore. I believe this was
I think Queenman actually already debunked
that this was gore. I believe it was Queenman uh showcasing that
it was just some typical thing that butchers do in some Middle
Eastern countries. >> Oh, no.
Oh, no.
Oh, it's Stardust. This is Stardust's employer, by the way. This
guy edits for Stardust and he's going, "Oh, that's what it is."
That's what it is for everybody. Every single person didn't realize
that this is what it was.
Right? That this And it's like, "Dude, I The funny thing is is
it's literally still racist, which is Oh, wait. What did I say?
She edits for him. I thought I said he was her employer. Did
I say Oh, sorry. I said employer, not employee. My bad. I reversed
it. Yeah, I I said employer. I meant employee. She's his employee.
And he's like not even standing up business for her, okay?
And it's like it probably is racist. It probably is a cow just
to like with Stardust. I mean it is. We saw Substance's thing,
right? Just to [__] with her on the basis of her
heritage and complaining about anti-Indian sentiment and all
this.
But it's not like gore on the level that she should be freaking
out about. It's like not even Dude.
It's crazy.
Yeah, it's like an animal carcass,
Yeah, yeah. It's not I wouldn't call it So I don't know why she's
still saying that. I thought this was actually debunked on her
stream.
I thought this was like something she acknowledged and then said,
"Yeah, well, it's still disturbing to send an Indian or something
like that." So I'm
That sounds possible. If we've learned anything from Stardust's
stream it's that basically the act of speaking prevents her from
forming memories. And if she's speaking while saying something,
she won't remember saying it. She cannot remember the the things
she herself has acknowledged. She is like a goldfish,
She's like a very very old hard drive that can only Well, actually
I think hard drives are still like this. Can only read or write
one of the two operations at any given time, okay?
I'm a little surprised she's still going with the gore angle.
Uh and as far as in justifying that I mean let me give you my
opinion. Where is this clip? Where is Substance? Substance, we
need this clipped, man. We need this Hold on. I'll put the timestamp
in chat. We need this clipped, okay? This needs to go out.
That literally her employer is actually going on other streams
and saying, "Well, she's admitted it's not gore. It's like it's
not clearly not gore. I don't know why she's lying about this."
Her own employer, man. >> and I'll see if you agree. I
think the reason why she's calling it gore is the same reason
why she's calling it like what? A racist attack. Like she's playing
it up as much as possible to be able to smear people that she
she doesn't like. Like She's objective so interested in the Substance
tweet if Substance wasn't I don't know a clipper of Queenman
and Jstark. But it's a way to be able to get to them. And so
she'll smear Substance and she'll smear Jstark and Queenman in
order to like I don't know. So And she'll polish Destiny's disgusting
Hold
To polish Destiny's too. She's willing to do anything. She's
willing to debase herself in any way
if it means getting back at me and
And by the way, I understand the hatred for Queenman. Not for
me, man. I didn't do [__] But she's just objectively
lying. She's got to know she's lying. Uh she's either lying or
exaggerating to the point of absurdity. I don't But but
Dude. Oh, I didn't know it was this bad.
Like nobody informed me that it was this
This is insane. Her employer
is out here
just calling her a liar.
It It's like she's so histrionic that she can't see reality.
Dude, Stardust Wellness checkup Stardust? Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Guys, this tweet is about to become a reality. We need a wellness
check immediately. And not just from toilet Guys, what is happening?
Is she okay? Is she all right? Is she going to be okay? Dude.
If it was bad already, it's only getting worse, all right? It's
only getting worse. But yeah, this is definitely
what I mean to say is it's either yes, it's either she's maliciously
lying or she's just being excessively hyperbolic
out of
emotion, I guess. Um I could see what you mean. No, it's not
even emotion. That's Dickish better lock this down. It's not
emotion because it's three months later.
I could believe emotion in the moment. I can't believe emotion
three months later after there's been a content cycle on it,
after you did your PowerPoint presentation. It is no longer emotion
about this picture or anything to do with the situation. It is
just obvious mali- manipulative malicious lies
because she is a unprincipled
He's just an unprincipled like wretched waste of space.
Shouldn't have any position on the internet. Shouldn't be doing
anything. She has to go back and and basically
beg on her knees for scraps to the D'Angelo community, to the
Destiny community, trying to find anything she can because she
can't be relevant on her own. And for some reason she's decided
internet relevance needs to be her thing. It's not going to work
out. It is not going to work out at all. Say it unprincipled
cow.
Hey, that's how Stardust views herself dickered as the cow, okay?
I would never. I could never.
Well, I could, but I just
Dude, I think that was on the stream I had with Straight Rate
on on Stardust. I think that's what that was.
That's where she did the self-inserting as a cow moment. I can
see what you mean about like um excessive like hyperbole. Like
calling it a racist attack. Uh if you get down to the messy messy
gritty, probably not. Um but I get where she get gets that from,
right? But for example, saying that Jstark continuously
justified and defended it.
He didn't. Substance got banned during the stream that she was
watching. >> I can't remember. Didn't he
Wait, didn't he ban Substance like for a temporary period and
then say like if the period that Stardust requested.
>> you talk to me, I'll ban permit. I can't remember what
exactly happened. Uh I
Yeah, but Jstark said that it was bad,
Uh no, he did. Yeah. Although like he he did and then laughed
about it. I I think he's kind of like
How how do I put this? Do we not laugh at bad things?
Do we not laugh at things that we ourselves say like you shouldn't
do? Is that not a thing on the internet?
Are we really going to pretend that that's not a thing? You can't
laugh at some somebody who's doing something bad?
Really? His actual opinion seemed
because part of him just also wanted to make fun of Stardust.
So I I don't know what his real opinion was. Also I had a fever,
so I'm probably misremembering wildly. So.
Okay, but He wanted He wanted to debate me on this, by the way.
And he I wanted to talk about why you were saying in her chat.
Like I think Gilded Poo is making claims, too. the stream uh
from my chat. So I'm like bro, there's nothing here to debate.
If you came to me and you just said, uh I don't think this was
bad of Substance to do, in fact it's funny, I would just say
okay. Like I I I just I I I don't know what I was supposed to
debate him on. Debate who on, sorry? Jstark? Jstark, yeah. He
was trying to invite me on his stream and I as I said, I had
a like 102 degree fever. Uh then Beckett was trying to set it
up and and yeah, it was dumb. But yeah, I'm I'm not entirely
sure
Jstark's position is from memory. Oh, I want to point out that
everyone was upset with the replacing white population joke,
but not the hashtag bioweapon joke. Very telling. Okay.
At StardustIRL, remember when Jstark and Kleiman went on rants
about how the no bad tactics, only bad targets virtue is bad,
lol.
Yeah, I I wasn't defending this at all. I I was literally saying
it was wrong to I was laughing at Stardust's reaction to it,
which is obviously histrionic,
a combination of histrionic, overly emotional, lying, okay?
It's a combination of a bunch of bad things, but I'm mocking
her for her stupid reaction.
I'm not mocking I'm not saying it wasn't racist. I'm not saying
anything about like Substance's thing. I said it right off the
bat, oh I think it's racist. I think it's bad. I think you apologize
when you violate your own principles because you are keeping
your own soul clean. You're actually trying to actually operate
under some principle
That's what you're doing. So this is what I wanted to debate
him on was him trying to make some point about how me and Kleiman
are hypocrites.
That was it.
Yeah, okay. We continue.
His position was very
like he was trying to be serious while also entertain.
I mean, I can give you a clip if you want. Hold on. Give me 2
seconds. the issue further. This will be one of these two clips.
One, you're calling me a cow. You're saying it's a threat to
physical violence. And now you're denying that there's a racial
undertone to this. I said to make it clear it wasn't racist.
I don't actually wish that. I'm just aiming along. But Jesus
Christ, man. Like you can't just say, well this isn't racist
and it's now not racist, right? You can't do that. So Jstark
says that it's racist and then he says that oh Substance should
have said that the cow was actually her. And so it's a directed
physical threat, not a racist attack.
He's saying that that would have made it better. Haha. I'm memeing.
I'm joking. And so she's literally sitting there watching the
clip. I mean
I mean, any way that you frame it. I just think she's being a
totally malicious freak over this stuff. Um Um yeah. >> she
doesn't know about the PV stuff. And so as soon as Jstark weighs
in to be able to disagree with her, she's just like smearing
the guy. That's all that's happening there.
I I mean, I progressive victory. But either way,
>> But either way, uh I wasn't commenting on that. She
was wondering why something was happening. And I explained why
it could be happening. Honestly, probably the explanation is
the person was just you know, [__] on them. Destiny
was [__] on them, so they [__] on him
back.
Hey, you're [__] on me, so
you're [__] on me, so I'm going to [__]
back on you. Obviously. As I said, it could be that she's lying,
I guess. Uh it's also possibly the case that she's so emotionally
invested in all of
that she's just saying I I feel like the only explanation here
is that she's lying. I think the difference is she's either in
the heat of the moment What's up, DK? lying or she's like coolly,
maliciously trying to [__] with Jstark by lying.
But if I >> lying is the only answer here now. I read it
as a crash out, personally. That's not That's literally just
using different language to avoid the actual allegation. Can
this guy just engage? Well, actually I I read it as a crash out.
Yeah, but what did she do because she crashed out? She l- she
l- she l- she lied. She's lying
repeatedly,
over and over again. You know, uh people say like really insane
[__] when they're crashing out. Um but yeah, if if
if she's knowingly saying false information,
uh you know, um basically what I'm saying is either
uh I I kind of agree that like she's in Hold on. Is this Is this
the tweet where she says she has no idea about the supreme thing?
I already brought that Hold on, let me see. Dickers is linking
this one. Is this the I have no idea about what the supreme thing
is? Yeah. Yeah, I just she's literally I'm literally just pointing
out something that's in response.
She's going to after me like, why? I don't even know why.
I'm not entirely aware of the stuff with Supreme, but I definitely
don't endorse any of the accusations towards him. But you're
attacking the person who pointed it out. You're literally just
trying to personally attack the person who pointed that out directly.
Why would you Why would you just personally attack the person
pointing this out and then go, well I don't even know what that's
about?
Why wouldn't the first question be, I don't know what that's
about. What is that? What are you talking about?
She didn't do that, did she? Not even a little bit. Very >> Either
way, she's being dishonest.
It's just a matter of is it Is it What's the word I'm looking
for here? Is it something that she's planning or is she just
crashing out? But I agree that in either in either case this
is a pretty dishonest tweet. Mhm. I think she could possibly
I mean, I I don't think she'd like to hear it. But I feel like
she could probably learn from Substance's example, you know?
You crash out. You say something on Twitter that maybe you shouldn't
have done. You realize later that was bad and then you have any
principles at all, but unfortunately for us,
Stardust got no principles whatsoever.
Absolutely zero principles.
You know, you apologize. I think that could be a good resolution,
huh? No? She could or she could at minimum just delete all the
tweets and stop talking about it. Dude, like like I want to be
honest with you and I told her this, too. I said I don't I don't
care about the cow carcass thing.
I I don't understand I can't understand why it upsets her.
I I just can't relate. I even say
Cuz it makes no sense. Cuz she made it up entirely just to go
after somebody who clips my content, Kleiman's content.
Is it's a totally obvious malicious lie? She's quite literally
cry bullying because she just wants her way and she knows she's
got people behind her who will retweet anything negative she
says, especially if it's a lie. Hey, is this a totally Is this
a totally like disgusting lie about somebody who these people
don't like? Yeah. Yeah, it's a totally disgusting lie, but I'll
get some likes. I'll get some likes and it'll hurt them.
That's all she's going for, man. this in I think the chat that
I I am way I've been on the internet way too long.
So like I I don't know if she's just not been subjected to that.
Has she like hid her hid
herself from the internet for most of her life? I I'm just really
confused on why this is an issue. Like when she was a creator,
she spent like an awful lot of time intentionally going into
like alt-right racist spaces where people would just like give
her racial harassment 24/7, right? That was what she lived and
breathed for a very, very long time. So she could
Honestly, in your heart of hearts,
what do you think the odds are that in one of these Discords,
one of these like alt-right Discords, okay, when she's going
to get into like StreamYard or whatever to go on a cozy panel,
what are the odds nobody sent her an image worse than that having
to do with cows specifically? I know she'll never admit that
even if it were true. I'm just sitting here and I'm like, "Dude,
somebody did that at some point. Be honest. Be serious for 2
seconds. That obviously happened. Come on." Clearly doesn't really
care that much. It doesn't get to her that much. Like there's
clips of Stardust on streams where people are calling her the
the peace lord, which I'll get arrested if I you know? So, she
clearly doesn't really give a [__] that much. Like
the tweets that she puts out are intentional race bait to to
rage bait. Hold on. I I did ask her about this, actually.
Specifically this. I did actually ask
Screw this. Her issue isn't racism itself, it's racism from people
that claim to be progressive. >> Stop. That was her issue.
>> Before you even start, stop. Before you even start,
stop. Before you even start, stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. So, she
doesn't care about racism. The worst part of the racism is the
hypocrisy or her. Is that what we're saying? That's what seems
to be the case from Yeah. Yeah. I think she even says this on
that stream as well. But that flies in the face of the literal
point of the stream where I cut against basically all of the
people in my chat, a bunch of people around me who are like,
"No, these people don't deserve consideration." I'm like, "No,
you do it for your own principles, not for
That's why you should That's why I told Substance you should
apologize cuz it's what you believe, it's not about what they
believe, right? I'm like, "It's actually wrong to go after somebody
characteristics
like in a in a specific targeted targeted way. Like I'm fine
for edgy jokes, right? But I'm not I I feel like I'm not normally
talking to somebody directly that I've no rapport with and doing
it directly to them. I feel like that's a little different, something
I wouldn't want to do, you know? Yeah, no, she does say that.
She does say that. It's very funny when she says that, yeah.
Yeah, she's like she's Yeah, she said something like I expect
alt-righters to be like that, but progressives are supposed to
be above it or something like that.
Yeah, I'm sure. I'm sure. I I mean, to be fair, I don't give
a [__] I'm traumatized because you're a progressive.
If Nick Fuentes sent me cow gore, I would just shrug it off,
but you're a progressive. You said it was wrong to send cow gore,
so the trauma is
That's not how this works.
Come on.
In what universe does it work that way?
serious, man.
Actually, it's just really gross when people are hypocrites.
No, I I do to a certain degree, which is why I'm glad that Substance
apologized for it cuz it was a [__] up thing to do.
But my my interpretation for why Stardust cares about it is cuz
it's like an ego hit. It's not necessarily that somebody's been
like, I don't know, targeting you racially. It's that you've
been like disrespected.
And I mean, being honest, right? It is an amazing one-two
when she says, "Boo-hoo, I hurt your sensitive feelings." And
then she gets retweeted by a cow head. It's bad. It's bad. It's
But I mean, as a one-two,
it is a bit of a She's literally she's literally sitting there
on the least moderated platform on planet Earth going, "What
are you, a little [__] You get your hurt your feelings
hurt on the internet today, you little [__] You get
your feelings hurt on the internet today, little bitch?" And
then she immediately goes, "This is traumatic. This is a borderline
physical
It's textbook cry bullying, right? She wants to be And by the
way, when when she's getting called out for her original tweet,
the the all diabolical rebrand [__] right? She says,
"Well, I'm I'm just I I just am that way. I'm just like I'm I'm
a I'm I'm going to be mean. I don't care. I don't care about
anything." That was her response, right?
So, she's willing to be mean to other
And then somebody hits her back and she goes she tries every
single trick in the book to make it something where she's been
traumatized and she's really [__] up and why would
these people do
Bro, what the [__] Very shmulian. Yes, we are we
are going to popularize shmulian, okay?
It is very shmulian behavior, isn't it? dude, it is. It just
is. It's a joke.
You know,
again, Oh, right. Oh, wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. That's actually
giving her a little too much credit that she might have had an
immediate emotional reaction. Her immediate reaction was actually,
"I don't really care."
Her immediate reaction was, "Did you even look to see if I was
Hindu before you did that?"
>> Hold on. Let's get the first tweet. The first tweet
is
Which one? Which one? Which one?
>> Did you even Did you even check to see if I was Hindu?
Imagine getting so mad at a comment that you send a pic of a
dead cow to someone without checking if they're Hindu first.
Like I don't even care about this, actually. This is the level
of liar she is. This is the level of transparently malicious
liar she is, okay? She went from this to doing a PowerPoint and
presenting it during Peasego's Wick panel thing. Absolute trash
goblin. Hold on. Let me what we have in DMs.
Oh, I didn't I didn't like these clips as much of the Mutahar
thing.
I I already explained it a little bit. I'm not really going to
go into it that much with Gilded Poo. You can't come back from
that. She could have literally just
said, "Lol, good one." and then moved on. Yeah, she could have,
but that's what I'm saying, right? That's the reason why she's
That's the reason why she's crashing out. It's just like a personal
disrespect that she's taken from it. I don't think she gives
a [__] about any of the um racism. She just said
that. No, she is not Hindu and she explicitly says this in her
little presentation to Peasego and Wick. She's not Hindu, but
because it's a cow, it's the Indian symbol of peace and it's
been desecrated. It's an attack on her culture, who she is culturally,
okay? >> said it was personal disrespect,
right? I I think that would be relatively fair,
No, cuz she's trying to smear people and she's trying to get
people banned from other spaces. And nobody's going to care about
personal disrespect, right? You've got to say they're racist.
That's true. Um I I did I did not like the Peasego thing, actually.
I was not a fan of that.
total piece of [__] by the way. Stardust Stardust
should feel betrayed if she ever watches this because this was
in her chat gassing her up the
I she was reacting to me reacting to that panel and laughing
at how dumb she
And this guy was in her chat gassing her up the entire
time, okay?
Um also, I just don't really like Peasego very much, but I kind
of felt bad for him a little bit. So.
Um cuz I I just felt this was all unnecessary.
The guy is just a [__] Who cares? Yeah. I mean, I
mean, am I wrong? Isn't Substance just a
I mean, he's not even like a [__] content creator
or anything.
That's what I'm saying. Yeah. Yeah. He's like, yeah. >> The
whole reason why she brought it to his attention is because I
think Substance clips Substance clips for Queenman, Substance
clips clips for Jay Stook, and then he started to clip the Peasego.
Yeah, I think it's entirely unnecessary. Yeah. Yeah. One thing
cuz I don't know if how much else we're going to
Helbent says, "I'll sub if you get marathon." Helbent earned
a timeout, actually. In fact, Helbent has been timed out for
suggesting that. He's an
But she doesn't credit you by name on her on her Linktree. She's
ashamed to say the name Gilded Poo.
Why would I be linked in her link? Wait.
He's editing clients. Oh, I didn't know >> was her.
>> me personally, me personally, I would be quite offended
if I was Paint It just says Gilded and not Gilded Poo. And if
you know anything about Gilded Poo, he's got the [__]
the the [__] the literal [__] branding
on all of his
He's talked about [__] everywhere, okay? All of his
Discords, [__] puns, okay? All of his all of his
inside jokes, [__] puns. He loves feces, okay? And
Stardust won't even say Gilded Poo. It's just Gilded. somebody
to do editing work for me and they wouldn't even quote my full
name when they were talking about editing credits, but
I could kind of understand why, you know, Poo, you know, like
>> India Oh, dude. That's more culturally insensitive insensitive
than anything we
>> What the [__] man? What the [__]
Hi, I'm culturally Muslim and Desi. Also, I edit for Gilded Poo.
Dude, that was that was a crazy joke to make. That's a crazy
joke to make, man.
>> And by crazy, I mean awesome, but also totally [__]
up in the context of Stardust getting like in people's face over
supposed racist attacks.
Yeah, okay. [clears throat] I could possibly get that. I could
possibly get that, yeah. Do you not find that like a significant
point of disrespect? Like I'm basically saying, are you prepared
to dock like half of the wages going on?
Nah. Is it not worth half of your name, though?
Yeah. No, like I I don't have I don't have an issue with that.
I I don't care. Like to be fair, also, it's probably my fault
cuz I did literally after she made the video after she finished
my one of one of my videos, I said something to the effect of
"Well, this is a match made in heaven, you know,
an Indian editing a video for a Poo."
There's something
Can I Can somebody get me Stardust like patreon link or PayPal
link cuz I think I found [clears throat] the problem. I don't
give her money. I could just give her money and then it she'll
she'll endure any level of abuse. I just have to give her money
and then she'll stop saying that I'm being racially abusive or
that substance is being racially abusive. Can we just give Stardust
like $5 each and then she's like, "Oh, never mind. You aren't
racist actually." Like that I don't
Um and I think she
>> I think she's got annoyed
By the way, Gilded Poo of course being the guy who just came
it just came out that he was cheating on his girlfriend or you
know, one of one of one of his Discord relationships to lie to
another one about whether or not they were
Right? That's who Gilded Poo is. We just did drama on this recently.
So that's him. And he does obviously he's looking to people over
Discord.
Is he possibly looking to add Stardust under the belt, okay?
Is he Is that what he's looking to do? >> She's getting
racist attacks even in the DMs of the client that she's working
for. No, this wasn't in DMs. This was in crazy amounts. Like
No, this was in the chat of some stream.
No, this was just in the chat of a
Uh this was not in DMs. Uh it was worse. >> Okay, so you're
publicly attacking her publicly racially attacking her publicly.
Well, it's different when I do it because I'm actually being
you know, I'm I'm I'm being silly, right? So that's it's different,
okay? I'm not I'm not actually you know, legitimately going out
there
I don't know sending her weird screwed up stuff. Uh but yeah,
just typing Gilded like I personally don't care This guy is like
pretty openly anti um what do you call it? Like um Islamophobic,
no? Is this guy like openly Islamophobic? I thought he was. I
thought he was like very much Islamophobic. Very interesting
that Stardust edits for a guy who's She's culturally Muslim,
he's Islamophobic. Is that also a match made in heaven? >> that
much but I can I can see why she would do it. Uh secondly, she's
only edited like one video of mine so far uh out of I've only
been have hiring editors uh commissioning editors uh very recently.
So I've been kind of shopping around. So I paid her and then
I went to somebody else and now I got a third person lined up
that I'm going to go to them and so I haven't
How do I put this? I haven't said all >> She's not an editor
on the channel. She just did it like one time and then you moved
on to somebody else. >> So far, yes. That's fair. I mean
I've seen the other box that it's like I can understand why you'd
want to pick somebody else.
I uh
>> it's nothing to do with that. Uh but but I don't even
know who the [__] Lonerbox is actually. So like whatever.
Yeah. If you don't if you don't like Pisko, I don't know if you'd
like Lonerbox. Um Are you generally a big fan of the Scottish?
I would love to visit Scotland one day.
I think
>> To be friends with the Scottish?
I'd love to visit Scotland one day. To be to to be friendly,
right? >> I'd love to visit Scotland one day. >> okay?
Interesting. Interesting. I love Scotch. I I would just want
to go there for the Scotch. That's basically Oh, you love Scotch.
>> Hold on. Elephant wants to be added to the call. Are
you okay? I thought he said I love Scots, not I love Scotch.
I like Scotch, okay. Um sure.
All right, nice. Give me 1 second. Hello Halberd, former friend
former friend of Stardust. Welcome to the stream. How's it going?
Good evening, gentlemen.
Uh I apologize. I haven't really been watching any streams tonight.
I've been out touching grass as one does. But uh Nobody cares,
Halberd. Why that That's immediately You immediately came in
and said something nobody cares about. I that timeout that 5-minute
timeout you earned totally justified. Nobody cares. Get to the
point. Um actually, I just want to let you guys know that I was
out doing stuff today. I was out being cool
Shut up. What is the comment of the contact? So I'll pick you
real quick. Has uh has Gilded been confronted yet on whether
he's flirted with Stardust or not? He's not until right now.
Go ahead.
>> No, I haven't >> Oh, no, no. I'm just Really?
You've you've flirted with everyone. Oh, that's really that's
really for her.
>> Oh, no.
Another totally degenerate
pervert
who draws the line at Stardust.
They will they will troll everywhere possible for anyone possible
in every racial group and every weight class, but they somehow
have skipped Stardust once again. Always the bridesmaid,
never the bride. >> Oh god. Yeah, I look I you know, uh
unfortunately thus is my reputation uh but I didn't create it.
So Well, did you tell me that verbatim that you've been actually
flirting with
Oh, you know there's a difference between acting flirty and like
actively flirting with someone, right? So Tell me sure, sure,
sure. Yeah, I mean I'm just I'm just busting your balls. I didn't
even know you were on call. I was going to call in to smart queen
in real quick. I like Stardust. Um I I think though in this particular
case she is being way too I told her this a while ago that she
needs to let it go. Um it it this is dumb. I don't I don't care
about the stupid horse or horse the the cow. Who cares? Like
I just don't I don't understand why this needs to be a talking
point. I mean I do know what she's doing. I just think it's she
needs to not stop doing that. Um like that's it it's the internet
doesn't care. Okay, bro. You're getting too big for your boots.
I don't Okay. Why do you look so much like friendships that I'm
not aware of? Um but like why? Why Why do you like Stardust?
Why do you like Stardust? I don't think I I I don't think I've
ever seen anything that's like I don't know redeemable about
Stardust.
The funny thing is Okay, the very funny thing is about this.
I've been on a call with Queenan. He knows what I look like.
I told this story before, but he saw me and he's like, "Oh, no
way." He smiled the second I turned my camera on. He goes, "Dude,
no way." And then he goes, "I'm still going to tell everybody
you're fat." What a prick, man. You don't hate Queenan enough,
okay? You don't hate this guy enough. >> I've only seen
reasons to make me hate her and then like vaguely dislike her.
Um Such thing you can take out to perform me. I thought that
was when I thought I was like a week away from getting a YouTube
channel back. And so I had my camera and [__] set
up. I had it all set up and ready to go. Unlucky, man. Well,
I guess the immediate things that the thing that comes to mind
is she at least to me so far is pretty loyal. So you know, that
means a lot to me. And
so far anyway hasn't had like a psychotic meltdown and leaked
all my DMs on the lolcow farms, which also means something to
me.
>> So by yeah, I guess judging by your track record that's
like a that's a new thing for you. That's a new level of a new
level of trustworthiness.
I've also I've also I've also talked to Stardust like off and
on for a while, you know, like I we we have some mutuals. So
like it it it's like you know, it's it's whatever and and we
have interesting debates behind the scenes, you know, like you
know, the normal kind of stuff, you know?
I disagree with her political
So if your YouTube is came back, you came up. 100% yeah. It I
think for me it'd be a better way to make money. Although I'd
probably do two different segments.
I think I'd do like more serious stuff with the cam on. Like
the what do you call the um I think I'd usually do like politics
stuff with the camera on. And then I might go back to the penguin
for doing There's some things I just don't want to say with my
face.
You know what I'm saying? Like if if we're snarking and stuff
and and around, I don't want to say that with my face.
I'll I'll feel like I suddenly becomes real. I want to hold back
a little bit, I'm just telling you. I think I'd get used to it
though a little bit maybe. Maybe. Like what?
Like the soft A for Stardust, Sophia? Like the soft A is probably
not something I'm going to say with my camera on ever.
>> Not intentionally at least. Not
Sure hope that doesn't slip out. >> Quickly on
>> probably half of the stuff she says along with everyone
else. So like you know, whatever. But But no, I I I think that
one of her biggest issues online is she needs to understand that
this isn't normie ville.
And she's trying to dredge this normie crap into the internet
and and no one cares. Like that's a fundamental issue. She's
really not. She's not trying to drag any kind of standards into
the content creator's sphere. She just has certain people that
she dislikes and so she skits and rants about them and like smearing
them. That's all that's going on there. There's no principled
like kind of like I don't know introduction of new standards.
That's not what's
Oh yeah, I'm also not doing the voices. The voices will be under
control, okay?
I could be un covered by the YouTube amnesty rules. The amnesty
rules only covered people on COVID and so COVID misinformation
and election misinformation. Those are the only two things you
could get unbanned for. Any other any other thing, you're not
eligible for the program. >> clear. I'm not talking about
standards at all. I'm just saying like normie arguments regardless
of whether or not they're rooted in any kind of moral standard,
right? Like complaining about gore, I would make the argument
is a
argument, okay? Like I I I could not give a [__]
less about gore. I think gore is boring, okay? It it like and
the reason why I think it's boring like just go watch a [__]
modern horror movie for like 20 seconds and then look at the
severed cow head, okay? And then tell me which one's worse. I
would argue the simulated gore is probably worse. So I in terms
of it being graphic. I got